okay so we will continue
with
carlos and anand well like we said we
have a day and a bit before the match
and let's see the next game that
maybe tiny bit less happy for
alan of course okay
e4 of course those players can play
every opening that you want to imagine
e4 default you name it everything you
want they can play
c5 by
anand actually this is fascinating to
see those games one after the other
so in 2008
i think it was eight we've seen this
super sharp
sicilian night of attacking everything
hanging
crazy
okay
bishop b5 check
you know
usually it takes people to get to 50
years old to start playing that solid
chess
cards and did it like you know
in five years
like playing very solid
i mean actually this was played a lot by
another great player he played it in a
match against guelph a few times kramnik
in the candidate matches i think in 94.
it's a very solid line
okay i played it also tiny bit with
white and black but of course not
not like those
great players but it's just you know you
want tiny bit to avoid theory you want
anybody to play solid
it's it's
every night of player has to learn this
a bit bishop d7 is considered
the most
principal
solid approach
knights d7 or knight c6 are the most
fighting approaches for example if we
will have the match i mean you know we
will have this position in the
i think we might see one bishop b5 by
carlson
i mean why not
take take
c4
before the knight gets into c3
okay c4 is being played
knight to f6
knight to c3
g6
okay basically what what does what is
white playing for something like this
basically just having a
marty position
okay something like that
white is tiny better just tiny bit more
space
tiny better for white
okay nothing nothing dramatic but
maybe even like tiny better for white is
not the most the best expression maybe
tiny more comfortable to play but
this is where they are heading okay g6
bishop g7
f3 there were some very big games
involving this line first castle it's
just a very beautiful line
actually
no
yeah castle
castle and now f3
and now black has a very cool idea
rook c8
taking this pawn
and now this crazy move
d5
anyone seen this before
no okay i will give you
i mean this pawn is only under attack
three times the the most guarded square
by white
but what is happening here you get tiny
bit you think
well what happened if white okay if i
take with this c pawn
maybe rook take knight for free is not
bad
but what happened with this critical
move
take it with the knight
so i cannot take it with the pawn
but what happens if the knight takes
e6 that's that's the brilliant idea and
this is considered equal for black
half
so this why
carlson's first played
well not this f3 and the idea is that if
castle
you will play
british or p3
that's really the idea and
and the knight will be defended so that
after e6 the knight can retreat
and then it's normal position
an unplayed queen c7
okay but white is tiny behind i wouldn't
say behind in development but
black will make effort to provoke
weaknesses
so that you will have some counter shot
with
this bishop
b3
queen a5
bishop b2
knight c6
usually white likes the bishop on e3 and
the queen on d2
there were some
i i mean i wonder
if queen d2 still knight c6
if this move
is this move lego
i guess this move might be legal as well
which one
yeah queen c5 might be the thing but
queen c5 may be here
maybe maybe maybe just knight c6
because taking taking is very is very
nice for
black he gets his spawn
to control this central swell and okay
knight d5 just looks threatening but
really this is not much
black would like to exchange all the
mine without the minor pieces black is
just equal why why white
can claim something because he says okay
i have tiny bit more space the more
pieces we have the more i like it so
that's his idea
okay
knight c6
castle
no knight takes e4 because
the knight is defending it
right okay also tiny important to see
some basic tactics but
for example take
if take here i think first check is
quite strong
but
take
queen b6 and now
c5
good move
winning
okay
i remember looking at this game
actually i think i was doing commentary
for icc for this game
i think so
it looks like by any standards black has
to be okay here
and such a bizarre move
like
92 you don't really see that
and
because usually what does white usually
want to do white wants to play these
and put the rooks on open files d1
let's put it
d1 and e1 and then maybe play knight d5
at some point something something like
that
something like this
white wants to to play
but the problem there are some tactical
problems for example
i mean now this is no joke right
immediately this is kind of winning if
this always there is the intermediate
check and the queen's under attack and
just this basic pattern very basic
exchange queens removing a defender and
just a pawn up for black for example
so not very easy for white to build his
normal play
and this looks
by any standard you know if it wasn't
magnus carson with white you say hey
white is just moving the pieces he has
nothing there which is probably true
the thing that is amazing and that's why
i said
those are the types of positions that
carlson might want to play more
and anand just cannot play the way that
he has been playing the last year he
cannot you're the world champion you get
equality with black
the game should be a draw usually i mean
okay
really the the great players once they
kind of equalize with black that's it
it's all right i mean white has this
tiny pressure
almost impossible to win games with
black at high level world championship
matches very very difficult
that's it
but anand just fell apart here i mean in
many games and
again for our match it's going to start
in a day and a half
then a beta if you want
you know a nun cannot doesn't have the
luxury to lose those positions
rook d8
97 is a normal move for example
just challenging the diagonal rook d8 is
also logical which ideas
can you will you should you
suggest for black
five is kind of creating a lot of
weaknesses over there
but well well where do you will you have
any attack at all
and denmark okay i'll play king h1 i'll
play king each one
okay so 97 i mean okay and then what
but you will trade one piece
so so so let's say queen c5 okay
move
this
this okay beautiful now what
95 okay what but what
i mean nothing is probably it's actually
better the way than that an unplayed but
okay
yeah this wasn't a very pretty game but
i think that logically
when you see those structures
the plants for black are not played
actually the most
natural plan
the plants for black are
working
on an a6 b5 break
i want to get rid of this pawn
so for example rook fc8
a6 and b5
supernatural ideas all
rook fd8 e6 and d5
you want to break through i mean okay
your opponent has more space there is no
doubt white has more space
so you want to break through so either
e6 d5 and unplayed a6 b5 it can be
prepared in different ways but that's
where you want to go
rook fd8
bishop
queen b6
immediately right nothing to think you
see this spin
you go away
d5 immediately
okay big one
similar same ideas as before okay what
is his idea
this one three
what
i don't know what you're saying
if white if i take the pawn i'll take
the pawn oh yeah oh okay
what did you think
yeah never mind yeah if i take what then
i take the pawn
yeah that's that's what he wants to play
that's what he has to play
and it's going to take
it's going to take this one back now
it's it's tiny bit maybe more tricky
what happens after take who can
pretend to calculate everything perfect
and tell me
so
um
why doesn't that bishop
final answer
that's it
no you want to consult the crowd
friendly phone something however wheels
they have
nothing
working tonight
looking to that's it
okay
working tonight it is but
what would black play after all this
slide here i'll be nice and i'll
move
my finger on the board right that's the
best you can get
best
take
take
king move
take
take
take with a hook
look
now and move for black and actually this
is super important we will speak tiny
bit about calculation yes we are we're
giving cars in a non
the spot but we can learn actually a lot
from just this position what then for
black
ah queen e3 [ __ ] the night
take
take
move
chicken cake
take take
[ __ ] tonight
now this is something super important
what we just did
this is something super important
and you know what we're actually going
to take a timeout for a second from this
game
i will show you
kramnik against karpov game
very similar idea
you know when we calculate
we have to follow forcing moves we have
to we have to follow checks and captures
because jess is a game of material right
we have to follow those so we have to
follow checks
but what we really should do
after we finish all the checks captures
capture checks those are false line
that's false line
then we need to stop and see minimum
the next move so basically if you want
to think correctly you're going to tell
yourself i have to see all the forcing
lines
check capture capture check what we had
here nothing other than that look
capture capture capture capture capture
check and capture but doesn't matter
check move away from check capture
capture capture
this this is basically going from point
a to point b that's it everything was
false there was nothing
no way out now
you still need one more move after i
finished all the sequence of false
captures
what's now
one more move
and that's that's why i said one more
move
time out from this car center
let's look at
what what that's what happens with the
pieces that's what happened to
undefended pieces right i mean what john
nunn was the one saying it right
loose pieces drop off
this
beautiful okay
just jumping into the middle quickly
okay
here you know you can have all of your
big huge puzzle
so
take that was played
is it right is it wrong
i don't know
what what what's happening after this
line
after bishop take g7
take the bishop excellent
but cringey feel this king move
somewhere
knight f5 i take the knight
knight x look
how much material are we speaking about
you gave how many points
what which pieces why it gave why it
gave
go first to bishop
okay luke knight bishop
and and he took and he took a queen and
a pawn and now one more all those were
forcing moves capture capture check
capture capture capture one more move
for white
queen whale
queen to g4
okay i will play ponte queen
oops
queen beast queen b3 is not bad what's
your idea with queen b but it's not the
best the right moves
which pieces
right but i can move the bishop for
example from b7
to d5 to protect the knight
yeah i was all over the knight from c4
to d6 to protect the bishop but
right way of thinking
okay well we will get it
so once again here see magic finger take
take check
take
take
take
queen to
e2 bravo
you see luckily for chronic he sees that
too
but under undefended pieces
undefended pieces right
so we see all the forcing moves one
after the other forcing forcing forcing
forcing moves
and then we need to see what if we have
many times you don't have but if you
have one move after that does something
undefended
that's the right way that's why i said
your idea was correct
okay and won the game so you know
very good idea of thinking whenever any
of you gonna play games you're gonna see
the false remove seeing the forcing move
is not necessarily the big one
sometimes it's not that easy but it's
not the big one the big one is
what comes after
so
back to carthage no not really very bad
thing tactical ideas from carlsen anand
kamnikarpov
not really those that bad players okay
so apparently
carlsen sees that sees a lot of things
take
take
queenie one
i mean here
the position is oh
yes here quite amazing
i remember we were analyzing it and i
think
most simple players in the world will
play
the most logical move for black
not a nand
and i can think i can you know i think
he was really really really wrong not
playing what was being what was logical
so what is logical
take on c what
what is white threatening
if you don't know what your opponent
threatening then you don't know what you
can play or what you cannot play
white white white is to play we were
here an hour before
and we said do you look at the position
you say i do nothing nothing here king
hatred
white to play what would white play now
what is right straight in your head you
need to do it i do nothing what is white
straight
you okay with this
right so this is right straight
if we don't understand what is the
opponent main threat how do we know what
we should play what we shouldn't play
what we can't play what we cannot play
we have to
this is not the right move actually
not a right move
but one of us here is going to be
obviously playing better than anand
and play better move ah
i think a5 is best move to me
it's most logical by the way let's see
what computers say
i think it's a5
nathan
let's say can you get a flight to india
you need to say yeah i mean position the
position is reasonable i'll be obvious
second the position is reasonable and a5
is most logical
i think out of 100 grandmasters 90 would
easily play would play this move
honestly
like no
not saying anything i mean okay this was
really really bad game by anand actually
last night we've seen not a very pretty
game by anand and those are the most
recent ones no he better like you know
like
wake up
but yeah a5 what is the idea of a5
well first of all not losing the
material
and attacking those pawns attacking
those pawns
like just gaining some space on the
green side
we'll see it e5 quite a brave move
and now
very critical move
i mean
what does black one play here here no no
big threats here if you are black
what would positionally be your ideas
for the next few moves positionally
but um but you cannot get that i'll take
it
plus i am not even certain it's the
right thing if you will play d4 and c5
you know let's say that i allow you to
play that for a second
i'll play here
i i think i like white here
you know i put this mighty beautiful
blockade
those pawns are not really good you
think you have a passport you have weak
pawns they are stuck
they are stuck this is weakness forever
this bishop is blocked this knight is
incredible plus plus
this blockade is very good i don't think
you want to put your pawns on dark
squares though just my feeling i'm i'm
pretty certain about that
no but what you want to play
knight 2
exactly
think about it if you don't have
anything
concrete clear immediately no capture
improve your worst
piece
which is
you you will have a pretty blockading
idea i think that this is the direction
so carlsen says no
a6
and here actually best move i i remember
actually yes i was analyzing it i was
quite happy that
while doing this on icc that we found
the suggested best move i think it's f6
you don't you you don't want to allow
the exchange of bishops some people are
speaking maybe f5
i think f6 maybe maybe i don't remember
yet take but take take we know is very
questionable i think after some time
f5 is tiny less than f6
okay freight
okay about for it
what what
yeah he's not here thinking about f6
he thinks that he's better after take
but he's wrong
i think it was f6
an untook which is a very very very
scary
way to play
knight f4
wow i mean this is just
right i mean
better or not better it's very clear
that white is playing big time
for free
take take d4
huge weaknesses
see how it works for him
and now i mean brave move but
this knight wants to in some spot in
some dreams go here i mean this this is
type of position like
completely neutralize him i mean okay
anand lost pretty pretty much
straightforward on the spot no fight
but it's no no no
not so pleasant to play this
g4 just keeps the guy
horrible nowhere
yeah so he plays this move
maybe some ideas to get the knight and
here i think carlson played super strong
that that wasn't a simple idea to see
so nathan you played better than a nun
can you play like allison
no why not
i mean logical
knight to d3
blockading controlling the e5 scroll but
that's logical for someone like me
well so karosen is better
that's all you want
yeah he played this move which was at
the beginning a bit surprising but
apparently he really wants to go here
here and checkmate
like not really easy to stop it you know
we're joking but
not really easy and then play it here
here
and push the pawn i think this was a
fatal mistake
but i think this position already
not easy
he played here
rookie five
now
what is the threat now
somehow i feel this is the idea that was
overlooked by anan
because if there is no this idea that
carson wanted to play
maybe not so is he
excellent job excellent exactly
and and
you know i always tell i when analyzing
when you are defending very simple look
at the square around your king
this square always always always always
whether you are
defending or attacking
or maybe one day i will even manage to
get an arrow
all right
seriously always look at this
there are no defenders
white is attacking with the queen a
knight a rook potentially another piece
heavy burden for this knight
too too much
you need always to look at the square
around the king it's very very simple
if that square is you are in a big
deficit of pieces though big danger for
black it doesn't mean that white's
attack always successful or black
doesn't matter but it just means that
it's very dangerous there are no
defenders
does that mean it's more likely that a
sacrifice works of course there's just
no defenders
so
1987 nothing to do you move the king
away
just taking just attacking the pawn
amazing
if anything steps on d8
knight f7
queen a6
and now typical move maybe i
i think
that's colorful i mean there were ma
maybe other ways to play maybe but
what's the rush
you know what a nun did here
he resigned
he resigned he has no no way to play now
this is not a very pretty position when
you're the world champion and that's how
you get
pawn is going to fall horrible pawns
you're going to get checkmated i mean
he's like
you know he's been shot poisoned stabbed
drowned like i mean this position no
white won this on every level
yeah and and the
annoying part for you know think about
just okay grandmasters like just
grandmasters that were watching it
like what's that i mean that was it
wasn't that carson played as
good as possible
but the nun played
like honestly
natan that is probably less than 2800
rated
suggests and i know for myself i'm much
less
but we would both play the same move
instead of moving a rook that is on open
file
push the pawn
attack the white spawn chain
get something in this direction just
gain some space and attack some
weaknesses this was actually the the
critical moment the second one also very
questionable to play the move f6
it's not pretty
but
your
look
this move is not it's not the prettiest
in the world but black position is
not it's not totally clear you will say
hey this bishop is ugly okay but
the king is safe
and this pawn
this pumpkin can become weak in some
situations
i mean it's not let's just see i mean
okay i know that it's freight and this
okay you know like
it's not that okay suggesting hook d1 is
best move give some advantage i think
some lines are even less okay we are at
0 3 best lines for white on computer i
remember f6 was not so so clear i mean
even if you are that advantage
it looks somewhat better than
the way the game went one-sided so we've
seen
just like yesterday one game for an end
a winning in complicated positions
tactics
he might have but better preparation
well better for him to have better
opening preparation and maybe he can
surprise with some lines
uh
i think the first few games going to be
really critical i mean if the first two
games will be equal let's say two draws
and you see a nun playing comfortable
okay like no not like that he's almost
lost and
somehow making it all then you just know
okay he survived that day he's not gonna
survive another day it's just very clear
right like in a boxing match right your
round number one or two one boxer is
punching the other no knockout nothing
but it's just clear okay where it's
heading so that would be interesting how
the first two two games i think will go
white and black
fanan's gonna play there like a world
champion and gonna be
all right it can be interesting match
like
i mean it's a short match in a 24 games
match i would really think zero chances
for anna like really really really
really like
i mean right now i think the
betting ratio is one two three
i would say that in favor of cars and i
would say in a 24 match
no 1 to 10 you should take i mean really
it's
just like
you cannot have 100 whatever points gap
and survive
24 games
match
but 12 games what does it mean it means
that anand can steal
a game
and then if he's not really easily
losing
there'll be a lot of pressure on carlson
you know carlton didn't play many
matches he played
quite bad many decisive games
he lost in london will remember the big
stories game 12 and 14 and somehow
qualified
so will be interesting and i'm i'm
pretty certain that everyone who's going
to be awake at
3 30 in the morning locally
you